yeah so let me start by my introduction
uh my name is dishant
and today I'll be talking about
asynchronous programming and actually
it's my first talk at a conference like
this and in fact this is the first time
I'm speaking in in a room full of this
this much Gathering
uh so yeah over the years I I had the
opportunity to work on various web
applications ranging from very small
applications to large and complex
systems
uh so that I uh that I got introduced to
asynchronous programming and I'm excited
to be here to share my experiences and
insights and on how you can achieve
concurrency and scale your applications
to like millions of users
like
so the to the first thing I'll start
with is by asking a question uh how many
of you have heard developers say that by
implementing asynchronous programming
their code is now running faster and
they are able to scale very well
amazing and how many have already
implemented asynchronous programming in
any of their projects right so I I am
assuming that you would have used one of
the methods I'm going to discuss as we
proceed in the with the presentation
uh so if I try to explain what
asynchronous programming is uh let me
take a small example to explain this
uh suppose we have a task to figure out
if the number is prime or not so what's
the first step you you write a function
which has which actually does the job
for you with actually uh data mines if
the function uh if the number is prime
or not so as soon as you start the
function as soon as you run the python
script what happens under the hood it
under the hood is a python process is
started and the CPU starts doing its its
operations and start calculating if the
number is prime or not
now in this case uh the CPU is being
utilized the CPU is not sitting idle the
python process is working and everything
is working fine but now if you take an
example of reading a file from the disk
uh what do you think who is working
under the hood even though we have the
python process even though we started
the python script but under the hood in
this case the disk controller is
actually responsible for reading the
file it's not CPU it's not the python
process so what is python process and
the CPU resource which is being allotted
to that particular python thread is
doing that the in in this case the CPU
is setting idle the python process is
sitting idle and we are actually letting
our python process and the CPU to sit
idle and do nothing
as a solution to this we have
asynchronous programming so this is a
type of programming in which we can
Leverage The Power of concurrency and
parallelism and Achieve uh like do
operations parallel to each other
so uh in in this case let's suppose we
Implement a code in such a way that as
soon as we come across a function which
do not need CPU we spin up a new process
all together with a whole with a
different memory with a different CPU
resource allotted to it
and now we have multiple process uh
which are doing our job so in this case
as soon as we spin up a new process our
main python process is not blocked and
we we can continue running on Main
python process which now now we have now
we have parallel uh python code running
uh it will it will be faster
right
so now that we know that asynchronous
programming is great we can actually
scale our code and we can actually run
our code very fast using this technique
uh figuring out where these techniques
can be useful is is very important so if
you take an example of prime number
again implementing asynchronous
programming in that case is I guess not
the best solution because in that case
we are already uh very efficiently
utilizing our CPU and by achieving
parallel programming in that in that
case we will only make make our code
less readable and more complex but in in
on the other hand if you implement
asynchronous programming in case of the
example when we are reading the file
from the disk uh that would be a better
option
right so uh you you can consider
wherever where we wherever uh our
application has to wait for the response
from any third party uh be it a network
call or reading from the disk or reading
from the database or any input output of
the file that is where uh the use cases
of asynchronous programming lies
right so imagine if we do not Implement
asynchronous programming in these use
cases what will happen we will implement
this solutions synchronously that is one
after the other right uh in in
synchronous programming you will see a
smart small amount of delay in every
operation and every task you are
performing right
and now if you are running at a very
high scale if you are getting uh
millions of hits per second uh those
small delays will cost a lot to that
company right uh that is why uh
asynchronous programming is um
can can be used as a solution to do this
now the question comes how python can be
used to achieve asynchronous programming
right
so in this talk I am going to discuss
four different ways to achieve python to
achieve asynchronous programming and the
four different different ways are
multi-processing multi-threading async
IO which is a python Library by using
salary and redis right and by the end of
the talk I will also quickly compare the
results of all the methods I'm going to
show you
so yeah
uh before activity of diving into the
methods I have just showed you to
implement asynchronicity uh
there is a small code snippet which
actually runs synchronously so if you
look at the code snippet what I'm doing
is I have a third party server which is
this httpbin.org uuid what it does is if
I make a get called to This Server it
just simply returns a a unique ID for me
and I'm iterating over over this and
making 50 HTTP calls so I actually ran
this when I was trying to implement this
uh if we see
uh you can see a small little delay in
every HTTP call right uh so I I already
know that fifth these 50 HTTP calls took
around 30 to 35 seconds to to finish
imagine if you have to hit 100 API calls
it will take around 1 minute to 80
Seconds to do this task is uh to do this
task synchronously one after the other
right
uh this delay actually costs a lot to
the company
and this is what we are going to solve
by implementing the asynchronous methods
so yeah
um
so the first way to achieve
asynchronicity is uh multiprocessing so
how I take multiprocessing is uh imagine
you have a python script and in the
terminal you can run the script manually
as many times as you can in different
terminals right so in that case your
python script will be running
independently on different Terminals and
different uh all those scripts will have
their own memory their own CPU CPU
resource right that is handled manually
in in that case
so how I take multiprocessing is simply
having multiple python processes running
parallel to each other
alternatively uh instead of doing this
manually in a terminal we have a library
called multi-process which provides us a
process class to actually create a new
process we have a Q class to actually
share the data between different
processes
and we have few synchronization
Primitives such as logs semaphore and
stuff like that
and what happens under the weight here
is the operating system is responsible
for allotting the CPU resource to
different processes so the library is
not doing anything the actual operating
system is responsible for giving the CPU
resource to different processes
so imagine if you have a a server with
four core CPU you can run four different
processes at a time so earlier what we
were doing was in in synchronization
method we have one process and that
process was responsible for handling the
tasks now we have four different
processes in which we can do the context
switch
and perform the same operation
hey
so I have replicated the same code which
was which I showed earlier
uh I again I'm making 100 HTTP calls to
the same server uh using the requests
method
and this is a small decorator which
actually works as a wrapper to the main
function and figures out for how much
time the actual function was running
so in this I've implemented
multi-processing and I'm using something
called pool
and what pool is basically the
encapsulation of all the processes I
want to run for this particular script
right
and in this instance my laptop is uh
eight core I am actually running eight
different processes at a time to do the
same task to actually hit the third
party API 100 times
and if I run the the script
we can see it's much faster than before
earlier it took us around 70 seconds to
make 100 HTTP calls but if you implement
multiprocessing it is going to take us
around only 10 seconds no 12 seconds
something in this range 10 to 15 seconds
right now the question is can we even
make it more fast so obviously yes we
are engineers
um
so what what was happening earlier was
we were having multiple processes and
the processes have threads in it so
what was happening is we have one
process and inside that one process we
have one single thread that was actually
performing the task for us
now what we are going to do is Implement
multi-threading now one process can have
multiple threads in it
again in this as well the operating
system is responsible for
sharing the CPU resource to every
process but the Catch Air is due to the
Gil which is a global interpreter log
which actually restricts the python
thread the python process to have only
one thread running at a time so even
though a process can have multiple
threads only one thread can run at a
time so if if we take a look at this
image we have a thread we have two
threads in the first process
the thread zero starts its execution we
come across uh a task in which the CPU
is not utilizing which actually we have
to wait for the response the execution
of thread zero stops the execution of
the next task starts from the next
thread right this is how we achieve a
context switching in different threads
in multiple threads we have
right
uh also one of the drawbacks of this
this method is Gil which uh which
restricts us to have only one thread
running at a time in one process but we
can still use this library to the use in
in the use cases where the output is
not limited to the global interpreter
log for for example Network calls where
we are getting the the response from a
third party server
right
so yeah the same code is being
replicated by using a multi threading
here I am using a thread pool executor
to do the same again I'm making 100 HTTP
calls to the same server by by using the
request Library
so if you recall in synchronization
technique it took around 60 to 70
seconds for making 100 HTTP calls then
we then we moved ahead with
multi-processing which took around
12 seconds now now we have implemented
multi-threading now we have multiple
threads in in our multiple processes
now let's see how fast is this
simple uh so now 100 HTTP calls took
only three seconds to finish the its
execution
okay
so this uh so the Third Way and the
second last way which is quite popular
in the industry it's heavily being used
it's called async IO it's a library uh
which also does something similar to
multi-threading it also does context
switching between multiple threads we
have but the catch here is uh earlier
the Opera the operating system was
responsible for sharing the resource
sharing the CPU resources to the
processes and the threats but here the
library itself takes care of that as
well
and earlier the context switching
between the threads was handled by the
library
but this library is flexible enough to
gives us the control to do the actual
context switch now we have the power to
control to control when our function is
going to stop when we are going to pause
our function when we are going to resume
our function and how we are doing
actually managing the context switching
between the threads right now uh this
Library can have follows the principle
of one process one thread at a time so
in in one process we cannot have
multiple threads we will only have one
thread but the context which uh which
the library which the multi-thread
library does itself we are going uh we
can manage it by ourselves by ourselves
so no OS uninvolved so if before diving
deep into this this Library there are
two concepts we which we need to take in
and take a look into and those are core
routines and event loops
so what core routines are so core
routines are basically python functions
uh which are actually using in which we
actually use a async keyword in front of
that if if we are using async keyword in
front of any python function that
becomes a CO routine and the power of
core routine is we can actually uh pause
that core routine and resume that core
routine whenever we want
right
and in this case and what event Loop is
basically where it handles it it takes
the responsibility of running all the
core routines in which uh which we have
in our event Loop so
so uh the the same code is being
replicated by uh by using this library
now in this instead of using request
Library I'm using AIO HTTP library
because
uh a request library is itself blocking
in nature and
uh to to
actually solve that problem we have a
new library called the iosg TV
so again 100 HTTP requests to the same
server and I'm printing the unique ID in
the terminal
so let's see how fast is this
so the multi-threading took around three
seconds to make 100 HTTP calls but by
using async i o Library we are we reduce
our time to only one 1.5 second
hey
so that's the power of asynchronous
programming right and the last way I am
going to discuss to achieve this is what
uh by using a library called salary and
redis
so salary is basically uh a queuing
mechanism for python so instead of like
starting the operations of a particular
task instead of executing a particular
task at that particular time what salary
Q does is we send all those tasks to a
queue
and we we cannot we do not execute that
at particular time instead we we send
all those tasks to a queue and that
queue is responsible uh of uh figuring
out when when the task is is to be
executed and where in which server in
which worker in which node that
particular task we have to send and for
that we we use message Brokers like uh
redis or rabbit rabbit mq
so
uh you can consider the architecture
like this we have our backend server we
have a salary queue and to pass the task
to uh from our server to this ldq we use
a message broker which is which red is
in this case I'm using and again when
the tasks uh took place when the
execution takes place of our salary
tasks we have to save the results of
those tasks in in a backend system and
again radishes can be used as a backend
system for for this technique as well
so if if we take a take a look at the
code
and
once again
so this is where I have declared the
message broker uh for for my for for
this particular example which is that it
is and again redis is being used as a
results backend which is that actually
where the
result of the salary tasks are being
stored and this is how a salary tasks
local tasks look like
again a request a get request to this
particular URL and by using this
decorator which salary provides us we we
can declare that this particular
function is a salary task
and
okay
again and in the main function I'm
iterating for for 100 times again 100
times this particular salary does this
fetch salary task is being called and
what this delay function does is instead
of executing that particular task at
that point of time it it pushes the
function it pushes the task to the
salary queue we have maintained
okay again 100 HTTP calls to the same
server
done done in 0.1 seconds
so we have reduced from 70 seconds which
took at the time of synchronization code
2.1 seconds by using salary and redis
so that is how we can scale our
application very very low level way of
scaling our applications and handling a
lot of requests
and yeah there can be multiple use cases
in bit for which we use a asynchronous
programming not only HTTP request but as
I discussed earlier
when whenever we are making a a read
from from the disk or writing something
to your database or reading from the
database or anywhere our application F2
has to wait for for the response
so yeah uh that's about it
[Applause]
thank you very much for the talk
um
updating slider
I think I have a wait
yeah
so someone is up Martin is thanking your
love for the talk and asking could you
kindly share the code examples and
slides okay you can find the link here
you can find the the slides and the code
examples here on my GitHub profile
how many threads can you have per CPU
you used 44 8 cores okay so we can
actually Define how many thread workers
we want but uh
as as we go go forward we we can
actually if uh
what what what do we say
we can have as many threads as we want
but it depends on the use case and it
depends on our execution on how many
threads actually we need so in that
particular example I used 40 threads uh
for for that 40 threads it comes out
that I'm able to make the 100 HTTP calls
in 0.1 seconds but if I've used 80
threads are underlying operating system
or the underlying process uh was not
able to perform uh in in an efficient
way because it took more time to do the
context switch between the threads
and it was more efficient when we have
less number of threads because the
context switch also takes time so it
depends on the use case and by hitting
trial you can figure out what how many
threads do you need for your particular
use case
there was something about the context
but
a question about the method like what
matters do you suggest for the
inter-process communication especially
from the sub process back to the main
process
pipes and map future results so I'm a
big fan of celerian redis I I would
definitely recommend celery and reduce
um why celery festered in async IO
it's not actually faster but in this for
this particular example it's faster so
there can be different use cases in
which we can use async IO and there are
particular different use cases in which
we have to use cellular and red radius
so for example if you are working on any
older version of python you cannot use
async Advocates that's not available for
older versions of python and suppose if
you have a use case in which you have to
run the salary tasks periodically if so
if you have a use case in which you have
to run any any particular task for in
every five seconds or you have to run
current jobs at particularly at a
particular time so for that use cases
salary and redis would be a better
option because I guess async IO does not
provide that that functionality but yeah
it depends on the use case which which
option you have to consider I really
like this question because I am a
JavaScript developer don't judge me but
what um oh what impact have you noted on
the maintenance effort on code that uses
these techniques during faster
well
uh so
again so since salary and radius is
helping us do our tasks very fast it
actually requires more maintenance it
keeps on upgrading and the maintenance
of each software development project
depends on the new versions We have uh
suppose
salary Library have their newer bunch of
versions which which gives you more
functionality and more optimized way to
perform your task you would have to uh
like upgrade and maintain your project
to keep up the market Standard and
improve improve your code
so yeah it's about how efficient you
want your software to run and how much
resources you have to maintain your
software's
answer but which of those four
approaches do you prefer on the daily
basis
it again depends on the use case so
for you
in your in your case like your project
uh so in my project so far I have used
both async IO and celery because it's
it's very hard to maintain a
multi-processing and multi-threading
code because it's it's very complex
you're right and very complex too I
understand as well it's not readable and
the rest of the two libraries provides
great support they have great
documentation as well so yeah I prefer
both async IO and salary but again it
depends on the use case
in order of salary fixed or
a race condition happen
sorry I didn't go in the other of salary
fixed or can yeah I didn't get the
question if you can
explain or rewrite it
I'll jump to the next one and there will
probably be one of the last one before
we switch
rooms
is multi-threading suitable for large
functions such as one for data
processing no
[Laughter]
thank you so much
[Applause]
to take